I actually think he's serious I don't
think he's just kind of catering to the
right wing nut jobs is this what it's
really come to really many of you have
been in the room when the president's
delivered speeches where he's talked
about his love for this country breaking
tonight new outrage and backlash over an
incendiary comment about the President
of the United States mr. mayor do you
want to apologize for your comment all I
want to repeat it but to condemn his
patriotism to question his love of
America I know good nothing his
patriotism I don't hear from him what I
heard from Harry Truman what I heard
from Bill Clinton what I heard from
Jimmy Carter which is these wonderful
words about what a great country we are
with an exceptional country we are